you know with a woman you know make a
house a home for a man but i suppose the
responsibility for us men we've got to
create an environment for women to do
that you see because i think if a woman
feels safe
she will submit to a man naturally yeah
but we can't as men demand it so that
means like mind and respect from you
it's because i'm not mad i think there's
a masculinity like a short like shortage
too yeah because there is it's really
like yeah a lot of guys are very
feminine oh totally totally nowadays and
and like it's also like a lot of guys i
feel like i work harder than
and like and i like i'm sorry guys but
some of those guys are simpsons
sorry i have to say this as a man i'm
sorry
[Music]
she was the husband of jezebel the bible
and that's what we are no no like no
no i i agree completely but like you
know what it is yeah as as hard it is
for some men to hear we as men yeah
majority of us
at one part of my life myself we are
absolute sims yeah right like and that's
like
girls some girls hands down
and the girls do you like absolutely go
for those girls but the majority of the
girls they like a simp once you're in a
relationship while you're not in a
relationship as funny as it sounds you
have to be a prick because like the
whole theory of
the nice guy finishes last year comes
into such a major play because of like
the girl needs to feel like
you as a man
if you like get into an argument she
needs to feel like you will tell her sit
down and shut the [ __ ] up
and she would like she would much rather
be some girls would get turned on like
all jokes aside yeah no no all jokes
aside rather than like a girl guy is
like always submitting to like oh yeah
she raises her voice and she's like i've
had this conversation with like girls
before we're like like you tell me
tell me i'm lying right now you know me
we're like why are we like like more
into them after we fight
there we go
a woman craves to be led
and if she doesn't feel respect she's
going to cause drama you see so i agree
there has to be a but i suppose it has
to be a constructive way how to do it
you see so well we like a guy that
doesn't treat like that treats us like
we're human there's nothing worse yeah
so we don't like we don't want a guy
that's just mean to us all the time for
no reason but like we know we're full of
[ __ ] sometimes
but you know when yeah cross the line
when you're trying to test the guy's
waters
oh you start something up to think oh
it's not really hard because i'm going
to make something up to say
you just you're yeah yeah yeah i don't
think it's conscious
look you could make a like
an argument of nothing like you could
literally be like you pass the trash can
right and you look at it and it's like
it's full right
and you're like
can you take the trash out and he'd be
like no and you cause an argument and
once once the guy has had enough not
necessarily to a point where it's like
it's just enough it is just enough so
he's entertaining what you're trying to
say sometimes guys will be like chilled
like it's like you have to mother them
that's what i'm saying
there's like i'm not done
that's the difference between like when
you're having a guy that's like look i'm
gonna tell you you tell him to take
trash out and he doesn't and he's acting
childish he acts childish to entertain
what you're trying to say but once you
go beyond and you start shouting and he
tells you yo shut the [ __ ] up
and you're [ __ ] you know it comes
down it comes down
it comes down to this it's timing so for
example a man's had the hardest days at
work yeah yeah he's literally worked on
his arse off for like 12 hours right
when he comes in
the first thing for the first 30 minutes
you've got to let the guy just
decompress decline yeah
we need to talk
i just need to come here to chill right
now
a wise woman once said this year once
your husband comes home let him rest for
like half an hour to an hour let him
play his games get out the system then
constructively bring out any issues that
you have breathe
if you do it straight away that's what's
crossed a fight
yeah so no not even that but like
relationship tip no exactly thank you
one look look
no you know what it is yeah
i worked in construction right i've had
i have a working instruction while i had
a girlfriend yeah the first thing right
and she she didn't live with me but she
normally stayed with me yeah and it was
a case of like
i come back home right the first the
last thing i want to do right now yeah
is talk yes like you know i mean like i
come back home the first thing i want to
do is i want to take my [ __ ] off i want
to chill yes i want to go take a shower
a long shower listen to my music play my
games whatever yeah and then she hits me
with that
the last look i've had to tell this girl
to shut you you know
number of times but then in in doing so
it led to like what i said was like oh
she was like damn like she he put me in
my place you know what i mean no which
was fun for a time for a time and the
equivalent i like to say is this that
it's like when the girl's on her period
that's when you got a beat
no it's not it's not on her period it's
like three days before this day like two
three i have to be sensitive to what i
say that she's gonna be you know i might
we might just start crying yeah
and i have to be sensitive towards that
in the same way we ask that once we've
come back from work that you'd be
sensitive that we're in a compressed
state but we just need time to chill
after we've done that then you could he
can upload what's going on right
destructively oh we're going to react
because we're going to feel her under
attack and i'm going to respond you're
going to respond you're going to start
crying and trust me as guys just how you
demasculate us when you say something
because what your words have power
because women have the power of words
you could say something that could
destroy our soul and that destroys us
for the rest of the day but this is
going to work depressed no but but but
this is the difference between men and
women it's like
men like if it was a man and a man
argument right and it escalated and you
threw hands right
like as a man right like the way i was
raised up and the way i've had arguments
and fights before it was a case of like
we got drunk we had a good time
something goes wrong we go outside we
sort it out we shake hands afterwards we
go inside and we'll be we
when it's between man and a woman is so
much different because the woman
takes advantage of the fact that like
you are fighting for your equal rights
yeah the way i see you right like right
now you fought for your equal rights and
you got them yeah i've seen everyone win
a sequel but there's still the whole
thing of like
if you hit a woman it's you're going to
jail well that's [ __ ] because you're
[ __ ] women
if she hits you hit her back
is that um you can restrain a woman if
she's holding a knife but you should not
you should but you shouldn't hit her
she's holding a knife
one thing if she's like hitting you
whatever but if she's threatening you
with the knife
no no
this is this is this was this was this
was my point right so when a woman
writes let's say we have an argument and
she throws fists right or like you said
has a knife against you whatever it may
be right
you as a man you know as a man as a
mammal you are stronger right so you
don't necessarily need to hit her you
just need to put her in a position where
like wrestle her down like
she throws a hand at you you catch the
hand and you pull attack
but
i can't lie to you it turns into a whole
like damn like like he really did that
like you know they get like as funny as
it sounds they get turned on by that
moment because you let her know that no
matter what you do yeah you will always
be stronger than her and the reason why
sort of in some weird kind of way and
probably if i'm right if i'm if i'm
wrong on this is that if they see that
they see that's a protector that's the
beast that i found yeah they're like
i want that beast to come together
it's like they call it the dark triad
traits where it's like there's certain
the same traits that